[Music]
on today's show we have a heavy one so
watch out for the little ears
in the room we talked about dating
somebody who's already married to
somebody else
we talk about parents mental health
issues we talk to a mom
about good touch and appropriate touch
with her young kids
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr john delony show
if you can tell if you can't tell my
voice has gone down nine octaves
[Music]
because i just got back from a family
vacation and it was a vacation
it was a celebration it was a trip
that's right it was a trip
into the woods of arkansas or kansas
they have different trees and leaves and
bugs and things there
and my body said we don't appreciate you
taking us there we thought we were cool
we are not but so we're gonna do the
show today four octaves below
we have some cool friends out in the
audience today we're with millions of
people
and by millions we've got four and we
got waving and everything it's good to
see everybody
and most importantly before we get the
show started james
what happened well it happened a while
ago but you're just now
um i only ask people how they're doing
once per month that's what
that's my caring quota my beloved
4runner got totaled
and it is no more so i'm without a
vehicle how'd it get totaled
a guy rear-ended me but
it was it really wasn't that bad except
that he had a winch on the front of his
4runner
oh so and mine is so old that
it's just enough to where it was a total
loss so
it was drivable but the back door
wouldn't shut enough to keep exhaust
from coming through
like through the crack in the back hatch
oh you're one of those guys that has to
close all the doors
i what a snooty like breathing chemicals
yeah oh here we go
um so the insurance company like give
you a high five and yeah
chick-fil-a gift certificate it's pretty
decent for a 17 year old car
but i just i just got to figure out
where to go from here i would just
imagine they'd come over to your house
why are you still at full coverage on a
17 year old car
awesome i'm proud of you yours is only
two years older
or newer than mine hey when mine gets
wrecked the insurance guy will come to
my house and he'll just
he'll open his arms and just give me a
hug and that'll be that give me a
lollipop like at the bank
he'll high-five me and say appreciate
you thank your donations to the
to the insurance come i'm glad you're
okay james is your neck hurt
no phew
well we solved that one we've got
allergies and car wrecks on today's show
and um other than that we're glad you're
here hey if you want to be on the show
we're talking about mental health we
talk about relationships we talk about
everything
right if you want to be on the show go
to johndaloney.com
ask it'll take you right to the forum or
you can give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
it's
two 1-844-693-3299 into my lowest voice
one
that sound good no james just gave me
the sign that said we're going to edit
back over that
it wasn't very good i think it sounds
cool but whatever all right let's go to
the phones let's go to
joshua in portland oregon what's up
brother josh how are we doing man
i'm doing pretty good how are you dr
john i'm all right what's going on in
oregon
uh so i'm calling you today because
i am the other man and i'm
struggling on what to do and how to
progress forward here
um what is the other backstory here i
don't know how much time i have to
really tell you
everything that's going on up to this
point so cut right to the stations i've
made
cut right to the chase so you made bad
decisions and you're the quote-unquote
other guy i'm pretty sure i know what
that means
um yeah uh she's been married
uh she was married for about a year we
you know first started
friends turned into a relationship now
it's about you know
nine months or night four months ago
after nine months of being in a
relationship she's trying to find out
she's pregnant
um with your kid she's pregnant
i doubt it's mine it's like very low
chance it's mine
um timing doesn't make any sense but at
the same time there's a possibility
and the guy the husband still doesn't
know about me
still doesn't know about anything that's
going on um
so why why are you calling me man
because i feel like my moral compass is
all over i've been wrong for so long
that i'm trying to debate about how i
step out of this
and do i tell him do i confront him
um i just feel like my moral compass i
mean
making wrong choices after wrong choice
how do i make it right
i'll ask you man how do you make it
right
i mean it's like i i have feelings for
her i love her and
i'm struggling on how to progress and
either phase out of this because i love
her
because i know it'll be best for a
family to be together hey how does this
end man
how does this end that her husband and
you and her go to go to dinner one night
and he's like you know what we're
married
but y'all y'all are more perfect than us
and so
my brother joshua i i
am handing this one off to you i wish
all the best
is that how that ends that's probably
not how it's gonna end
yeah zero percent chance dude that it
won't happen that way it only ends in a
ashes in a disaster
let's say she calls this her husband and
breaks it off and you all get together
for the rest of your relationship every
time she takes a call you're going to be
wondering if there's another another guy
every time she gets an email and closes
her laptop as you walk in the room
you're going to wonder
i wonder if there's another another guy
there's no way this ends right and by
the way you don't love her
she is a safe uh person to get into a
relationship with
because she's anchored in and you can
just trapeze off the side of this thing
with all
all the fun and excitement and joy and
you have no responsibility at all
none well i mean i'm trying to do the
responsible thing which is
i mean even if it is my kid i mean i
want to raise it i want to be with her
and
i mean it's just dude listen listen i'm
stepping out joshua
the responsible thing is to walk away
if this happened if this happens to be
your kid which you told me earlier it
wasn't
if this happens to be your kid then yes
this whole thing got real real real
messy
right and you may have a single woman to
start dating because
if um her husband's a person a character
he's probably gonna high five her and be
gone
yeah because she's having a baby by
somebody else
and god no you have don't go why would
you are you friends with her husband
no i'm not friends i've met him a few
times yeah
he's no reason to call him
i just feel like i've done so much
damage you know after
walk away walk away
you're like a surgeon who is taking
somebody's organ out and they realize
they cut the wrong organ
and they realize oh gosh i've caused a
lot of damage i think the best thing to
do here is to keep cutting out other
organs
and just keep cutting and keep cutting
and keep cutting
at some point the smart thing for that
doctor to do is to stop
put the scalpel down
yeah and you know that you know this
why did it take a phone call to a
stranger you know this man
because it's hard to hear it's hard to
walk you know i've
had i've struggled with uh finding
somebody you know that
matches me here it's just i'm tired of
being alone
you're still completely alone man
that's the farce of this you're totally
completely alone
you are somebody else's chew toy on the
weekends
you are somebody else's excitement
you're a video game for somebody else
but they have their stable locked in
thing
you're completely alone joshua and
that's what breaks my heart for her it
breaks my heart for you
yeah you know what i'm saying you're not
on a team right now
no no you're right you're right and
you're worth more than that
she's worth more than that her husband's
worth more than that this baby coming
into the world's worth more than that
so true you know what i mean am i crazy
i know no no you're not crazy you're not
crazy i mean bro you're a lord
you're totally alone right now
it's hard to accept it's hard trust me i
know it sucks it's awful
it's hard but i'm not gonna lie to you
do you have friends that know this is
going on do you have like some
guy buddies that you sat down and talked
to about this
well i have got buddies but the problem
is i haven't
told him about it because i'm ashamed
yeah my shame has kept me
you know kept them in the dark and kept
me from saying the truth
will they hold you accountable they
would
yeah so here's the thing man you can do
what you want
i'm gonna tell you right now i've been
around the block long enough to know
this thing
ends disaster
whatever fantasy you've come up with in
your head is not real
okay so if i'm you
i would probably talk to call my buddies
over tonight
and say we gotta have a talk
just so i'd have somebody with me when i
go ahead and make that other phone call
because you're not going to see her
again
you can make that phone call and says
i'm down i'm done
if this baby when it's born is mine then
i will step back in
but until then i'm going to do the thing
of
uh the right thing i haven't been a
virtuous person
i've been a person without character
i've been sleeping with a married woman
i've been violating somebody else's
marriage i'm out
walk away that's it man or dude
rock on no no you're right you're right
i just need a
i see you hear from somebody that i
respected of amount of characters so
it's just
it's hard for me to confess it to
somebody i know i got that i got that
hey that's that's the first step here
and that's what i'm gonna tell you to do
with your guy buddies so they'll be
there with you
and if your guy buddies are like my guy
buddies it's probably gonna get physical
yeah they're gonna wrangle me they
should that's what you're that's what
that's what made a character do for one
another that's what men and women of
character do for one another man
yes you called and you asked um
the right thing is this is over before
the day's over
and you got some guys in your life that
are walking alongside you
and not the ex i get that you're tired
of being alone there's a right way and a
wrong way to do that that's like saying
i'm tired of being broke i can go rob a
store
or i can start taking community college
classes and get three jobs
one of those are gonna result in money
at the end of the day one of those is
noble one of them is not
right and josh you know this man i
appreciate you trusting me with that
call
let me know do me a favor man i want you
to write me back and let me know how the
conversation goes or write me back and
say
i forget it dude i just decided i'm
gonna stick it out and see what happens
let me know that too
and i'll let the listeners know because
they're going to be interested in how
this one plays itself out
but thank you so much for that call all
right let's go to blake
in amarillo tejas como estas blake how
are we doing
hey dr john how's it going i'm all right
brother how are you
you know what you wouldn't be calling me
so what's
what what's happening man well uh
the gist of it is uh
my mom's my mom lives with me my fiance
and my baby
and she's here
she's locked in this fantasy of people
are after her
that she has been sex trafficked but
she's actually in the process of being
sex trafficked
um right now
um she's been in this loop for
seven years now or so she says it goes
all the way back to 1993
it's like the date keeps changing and
going further and further back
um have you ever taken her to the doctor
i've i've walked her into the pavilion
here in town and she walked right out
and she's smart she went to school for
psychology she her and
pretty much as far as i can remember she
has read
books on mental illnesses
she's she knows what to tell
counselors and psychologists she'll
she'll tell her story and it'll sound a
little nutty but she'll keep out a lot
of details
she'll keep out details as far as the
way she gets her information
is from her facebook feed okay
she uh scrolls through it and the random
stuff that goes up there are signs to
her
it's her being uh reading in between the
lines
okay so dr phil
yeah dr phil will tell you all kind of
things right just kidding i like doctor
well
you're the only uh psychologist that
i've ever actually
truly listened to you know over podcasts
and stuff
and i'm not i'm not even a psychologist
that's even that's even better man
you're making me feel good about myself
blake
hey so um how long has this gone on with
her has this been something you've dealt
with since she was
since you were a kid or is this
relatively new no i don't think so
um how old is she she's 54
okay and she's been doing this
she's lived with me for about two years
and it's been pretty much quiet
up until a couple days ago she left my
sister's house calling it a sex
trafficking house
uh putting notes on people's cars
and that dr phil and his people told her
that it's a sex trafficking house and
all these people that are after her
um and oprah winfrey
is in it somehow too uh even as we sit
here
and talk she is sitting on my patio
uh talking to herself on facebook
and answering herself on commenting on a
post that she made
there's oh there's like 50 comments on
there of just her talking to herself and
talking to these people
and asking questions and then giving
legitimate answers
like you should ask a question and then
they would come out
they don't say anything and then she
pulls
up on the answer that i don't know what
the answer was but
and only me and my brothers and sisters
and my fiance and um
my aunt shirley now can see it because
we're her friends
but so here's what i want you to do um
one of a couple of things is going on
here number one
she is um had or is having but it sounds
like has had a
a psychotic break
and she needs to get some help asap okay
um if you stay on the line here which is
down the line and i've
got some people in your area that i
trust in fact i
was on the phone with them um on another
call
getting some wisdom and guidance um
earlier today
and so i'll give you their contact info
and that's who i'm gonna recommend you
reach out to and they'll guide you
through the resources there
in amarillo okay um
you've got two things happening here
number one you've got your mom who you
love
do you have custody of her anyway or she
just crashing with you guys
no she's just with us okay
so no it's papers how is this impacting
your fiance and your little baby well
um megan sorry
my fiance talked about
she she brought it up to me that if she
ends up leaving it's not leaving me
yeah it's leaving for her safety
and as soon as the situation's cleared
up she would come back and i get that
and my son's safety my mom's not violent
she never has been i've never
seen her be violent but i understand
where she's coming from on that
and you've also never seen this right
i not like this okay
so i think your fiance is wise
um and i applaud her for having the
courage to tell you that
and so i would look at that as a signal
and
at some point you're gonna have to make
a choice between
mom and fiance baby
i i know and that's exactly what i told
her
and i already told my mom because i had
a conversation with her because she
busted into my bedroom
or not busted in this little dramatic
she knocked on the door and i told her
to come in
yeah kind of thing and she accused megan
of talking to one of these people
okay that are sex trafficking her and i
had a conversation with her saying mom
you can't do that yep that cannot happen
this is her home
and that's i told her that when it comes
to my son
when it comes to megan understand that
they come first
and kind of telling her without telling
her
okay now you need to tell her with
telling her
this is the time to be very very clear
my boss dave says all the time clear is
kind
and so i would write down on a piece of
paper probably type it up
and if your brothers and sisters are
there too that you all call a family
meeting
asap and type up the following
you are not in a being sex trafficked in
a sex
ring that is coming from my sister's
house period okay
um and make sure that all the facts are
written there
say if you were to continue to stay in
this house you will go get the
psychiatric care that you need
period and if you choose not to go
get the psychiatric care that you need
then you are choosing to go live
somewhere else
and that's going to be a hard
conversation that's going to be a
conversation full of tears probably
yelling
and whatever but you've got to draw a
boundary on behalf of your family
of your fiance and especially your child
yeah and in a perfect world she goes and
gets the help she needs
i'm not going to make diagnosis over the
radio but my hunch
these are very very difficult situations
okay
well i told her this last
tuesday i had to call out crisis
prevention
because she told me that she would have
to kill herself for me to understand
and from listening to you on spotify i
dropped the conversation called the
people that could handle it good for you
because i
i can't but uh they came in and she
willingly went back to the pavilion
and they couldn't hold her because she
didn't give a plan or an action
statement to it
and listen as an adult if
she does not make a threat on her life
in the state of texas they probably
won't be able to hold her
yeah right um feeling you're trapped in
a simulation or in some sort of matrix
doesn't make you dangerous and that
doesn't mean they're going to take you
this is going to be something that she's
gonna have to decide to do on behalf of
you
her family and that makes these
incredibly difficult
and so what i want you to know is doing
the right thing here is not gonna be the
easy thing it's not gonna be the
gentle thing it's going to be loud and
heartbreaking and all those things that
doesn't mean it's the wrong thing
i'm also not recommending you throw your
mom out on the street if y'all are all
pitching in on this i think you get your
brothers and sisters together
you'll talk about money you'll talk
about finances all that kind of stuff
that y'all gonna need to do here to
rally around mom
but your fiance is right because this
feels like it's escalating it feels like
it's moving in a direction
and whenever i'm working through these
situations i'm always looking for the
directionality
is this been way mom has been since she
was little this is just who she is
or is this thing moving at a at an
increasingly
faster speed towards a negative outcome
and i don't like the trajectory of what
you're the way you're telling me that
this has
come on and it's gotten more and now
she's getting a little more bold and
then she told sister and now she's
threatening to hurt herself i just don't
like the trajectory of this thing you
got to get the professionals in
and the professionals aren't going to
take her if she's not going to make it
direct
she's not directly a harm to self for
others so
get with your brothers and sisters make
a plan have the hard hard conversation
before you do all that get away with
your fiance
and your little baby and look your
fiance in the eye and say i'm 100 on
your side
and i'm 100 on your team and i'm gonna
do what's right here in this situation
it's gonna be hard and challenging and
i'm gonna need your support because i'm
gonna have i may have to kick my mom out
of my own house it's gonna be really
hard for everybody
um i may have to we may have to budget
for
mom's care because we're gonna all pitch
in um
but it's gonna be hard i'm gonna need
your help but i never want you to
ever question who comes first in this
house it's a little baby and it's you
so i mean it's hard hard hard brother
blake i'm sorry
um thank you so much for call let me
know how that conversation goes let me
know how it ends up and
we will circle back and i want to let
everybody know we can get an update on
your mom
all right thank you so much uh everybody
hang tight we'll be right back on the dr
john elon show
[Music]
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even text
chat counseling
with licensed therapists that are going
to help you
become a better version of yourself help
you
get on the road to being well go to
betterhelp.com for 10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
take care of yourself start today
all right let's take one more call let's
go out to brooke
in salt lake city utah what's up brooke
hi doing good how are you i'm doing good
you doing all right yeah a little little
nervous
are you nervous listen i'm not that good
at this there's nothing to be nervous
about
i promise you're a better human than i
am at radio so hey what's up how can i
help
um so we have a
five-year-old daughter and a
three-year-old son
and some neighbors uh two boys that are
seven and four
and they were all over at the neighbor's
house playing in the backyard
when
they wasn't they weren't being
supervised i guess and
they exposed themselves to each other ah
okay
was it just like i'll show you if you
show me yours
um yeah so i think i think that's kind
of how it started
um i think the seven-year-old i guess
because i wasn't there i was home with
our baby we have a one-year-old too
okay and wow you've gotta hold on you've
got a lot going on
it's utah here
i love a good utah joke way to go brooke
that's the first utah joke on the show
so well played so you got
three five and under yeah
wow okay so um your five-year-old is
playing with some neighborhood kids
and they end up in somebody's backyard
and there's a seven-year-old a
four-year-old a five-year-old back there
two boys and you're okay
and so to the best you understand how
did that play out
so yes i was so what we gathered was
like the seven-year-old
wanted everyone to just pull their pants
down um
and according to him he because we
talked to our kids afterwards separately
and
his dad said that according to him
they all just pulled their pants down um
and then according to my daughter my
five-year-old she said
that the boys did it you know my
three-year-old and the two other boys
but she said no and then when she was
climbing up the slide ladder
uh the seven-year-old pulled her pants
down and
um but then i'm not sure
how like the timeline really works but
then when i got there
because i was just taking care of the
baby for a little bit and i was walking
down there to
just kind of join them and when i got
there um
the four-year-old neighbor boy and my
daughter were
hiding in their blanket and i thought
that they were just kind of teasing me
so i
went over there and uh moved the blanket
and
they were both uh there with their pants
down just sitting by each other
okay were they touching each other
i don't think so i mean it kind of just
all happened really fast i think
they were like i think they were
touching themselves okay
um it was was the seven-year-old around
the seven-year-old he he was
in the sandbox with my three-year-old
okay and he told his dad he was trying
to tell them to stop
okay i think he knew he was going to get
in trouble for it and he knew what was
happening
gotcha um i don't know if he was
involved in that part at all
okay um and yeah and as soon as
my daughter saw me she just and she's
normally pretty reserved she doesn't
really like
like it wouldn't like in a when like she
gets hurt or something she her reaction
is to
be on her own so we kind of just give
her her space you know like
you know uh in like an emotional
situation but like
she just the second she saw me she just
came into my arms
yeah and was crying you know holding me
and wanted to go home
okay so what what was um
you you obviously talked to these kids
dad right some yeah yeah
how did that conversation go i mean
we talked a little bit um i think we
could have talked more
yeah uh because i just got my kids home
and my husband and i were talking to
my daughter he kind of she wanted to be
with dad
so she he kind of talked to her and got
her to kind of open up she was really
worried
about telling talking to us and so he
you know kind of gave her the confidence
to tell us you know
whatever that she was okay good for him
and
yeah he's a pretty good dad yeah um
but and then yeah and then i you know
conversed with the neighbor
over the phone just kind of figuring out
what
his kids were telling him but there
really hasn't been like
too much involvement from their side how
long ago did that happen this happened
um it's it's been a little while it's
sorry i guess i feel a little bit guilty
about how it's been about a month okay
i mean that don't go straight to guilt
okay you've got a lot going on
um so here's the the big picture thing
is this four-year-olds and
five-year-olds are curious
right so i'm not gonna lose my mind
i'm not gonna get angry i'm not gonna
blow a gasket or anything like that
right um it sounds like y'all did a
really great job of talking to her
and when both your kids when you got
them home your son and your daughter
and talk to talking to him
just to kind of get cut to the chase
here i there's a great book called some
parts are not for sharing
and there's important conversations to
have with
four five six seven year olds about
really
four five and six three four and five
about
you know who's allowed to see you which
is mom and dad and the doctor and that's
it always in forever
end of sentence right and unless
you know there's a grandparent that's
doing some caretaking and then
then there's a conversation that happens
and then once a kid gets to be four or
five
we're asking um can i come
do you need help with you know wiping do
you need help with in the shower
not just bursting in and saying hey i
get to be right i want to begin to teach
my kid that they have autonomy over
their bodies at a really really young
age
but stepping back the fact that this
happened
i don't like that seven-year-old kid
there there's something about that that
whole thing
feel if you were to call me and say hey
my neighborhood
boy is a four-year-old and my daughter's
four or five
and they were just standing there
showing each other that i wouldn't
that would make me raise my eyebrows
they're just kids having a
seven-year-old there
potentially egging it on and knowing a
little bit more
and getting people to do things they
didn't want to do that's the part that i
got a real problem with
so here's what i would do if i'm you
number one i would
ask um their these kids parents to come
over to your house so it's in
your it's in your kingdom for lack of
better terms
right it's on your turf and let them
know hey
we're i don't feel comfortable with our
kids playing with your kids
and um i'm gonna ask you guys respect
that boundary
okay regardless of how it happened i'm
not comfortable with it and this is
gonna be a hard conversation and make
your street weird
but your allegiance isn't not to the
neighbors down the street your
allegiances to your two little kids
okay yeah the balance here is that your
daughter's gonna feel like she lost some
friends and she did something bad
yeah does that make sense and so it's a
real careful and that's why i love this
book you read it with them
and you're able to look somebody else
wrote this and i think it's with
um i think dr jennings told me it has
turtles and fish or something i mean
it's a very
it steps away from from the situation
right and so it lets a kid see it
happening
um and because a seven-year-old was
involved
because your daughter says i think that
boy pulled my pants down
i want them to understand at the age of
five
that if somebody puts their hands on me
if i'm assaulted which is what that is
that mommy and daddy are gonna stand up
tall on my behalf
yeah and so what i would do is um
probably at least do one session with a
play therapist in your
in your local area if not two and to say
hey this happened
um can you help all of us with the touch
conversation
potentially get to the bottom of is
there anything super nefarious here
and then help give us some guidance as a
third party
with the whole family on how we can not
but
let our kid know how serious this is but
not shame them in the process and it's
just gonna be a delicate conversation
it sounds like and again you and i have
known each other for like three and a
half minutes right
yeah the fact that when she got home she
said i want to talk to daddy
and that tells me you guys are great
parents
and that you guys have set up an
environment where it's not a scary thing
to talk to mom or dad
is that fair yeah i think one thing that
was kind of a little soul-crushing i
guess
um was as you know
as dad was trying to kind of just
ease into the conversation she told
which i don't know
why um but she told him you know
that we're not gonna love her
and so that's i think yeah that is i
think that the advice you've given is
really helpful but i think that's like
the biggest
fear is i don't i don't want to
create some sort of i feel like it can
go bad two ways either
you know yeah i go play with the kids
and now it's mom and dad saying
hey doesn't matter what people do to you
mom and dad give permission for anything
to happen
sure or or like yeah i guess
you know like i don't want her to think
that like yeah we
if we see anything bad you do then we
don't love you
yeah so i i don't ever want to equate
accountability and safety with i don't
love you
in fact i want you to teach your
daughter the opposite of that
so i've said it on the show before and
my kids now they're old enough they roll
their eyes
my kids are 11 and 5. and i've got a
five-year-old daughter so i'm trying to
think through this in real time with you
okay
yeah if i ask my parents i mean i'm
sorry if i ask my kids
what's dad's one job they roll their
eyes like to keep us safe
and i've been telling them that since
they were zero okay
precisely for these moments because
no something's going to come up multiple
times over
and i'm going to tell my daughter hey a
boy
put his hands on you and only mom and
only dad and
only the doctor are allowed to touch
your bathing suit parts
and he did that and that is not okay
what's my one job and she'll go keep me
safe and also
say exactly and mom and dad will not let
you
be around people that are going to hurt
you or take advantage of you
and i want you to know that mom and dad
wouldn't talk to their daddy
because they should not be doing that
either and those that's is
as complex as the conversation needs to
be but i want her to know
that yes if somebody does something mom
and dad
are there when she's a child especially
and she may interpret it like oh man i
told mom this happened and now i can't
have any fun
that's gonna fall on you guys right so
that there's not a gap that now she's
not just sitting in the backyard
you know drawing a circle with a stick
maybe that's cool my kids like to do
that so i don't know
that she doesn't feel punished that she
doesn't feel that she's in trouble
as much as she's now knows that she is
safe
because mom and dad are on her side does
that make sense
yeah and that's a thin careful line to
walk
um and when you go to play therapy play
therapist it's a blast
they have a blast it's just a room full
of all this chaos and fun
if you get a dud it's not it's not that
great
the ones i've seen are really incredible
and kids
speak in play and so they talk that way
and so they'll
a good play therapist after a session or
two will be able to tell you exactly
what happened or very close to what
happened
and be able to walk alongside you guys
um
when she told you this is my last
question for you when she
told you i was i'm afraid you all aren't
going to love me
what was the response
um that she said it to to
my husband um
but we did talk about it together
because
you know we he came with her to me to as
we all talked to the whole family and uh
he told me that you know reagan
was concerned that she's concerned that
we wouldn't love her and
and he said that you know that's never
the case and
and so we just kind of had a little hug
puddle and
told her that we love her so much and
she's you know
our very first baby and we are always
going to love her and she's
always our kid and just kind of
milked just how much we love her and so
you've
you've created a platform for and she
knows this by the way
um tell her that every single day
make sure your husband tells you that
every single day make sure that's a
language you'll speak but more
importantly make sure that you show her
that every single day
right especially with a five-year-old
that's if
she's into it um that's a lot of hugs
that's a lot of eye contact that's a lot
of touching
on the face letting you know that she's
safe
that she's of value and that you love
her and
more importantly that you will intervene
you will get involved
okay so grateful that you called um this
is a
super common thing and so it's this fine
line between
uh and there's so many variables too
it's a fine line between
oh no and i don't ever want to steal
curiosity i want my kids to be curious
about everything forever
i want to i want to teach them that and
i don't want them to find themselves in
a backyard with two or three boys
being coarsed and doing something she
doesn't want to do i
definitely don't want her climbing up on
something and having some boy who's
bigger and older than her
take advantage of her i don't want her
in an unsafe situation where she's under
a blanket with some
other kid and so it's a it's that fine
balance between i love you
that's not safe here is what safe is
we're going to read this book together
we're going to go
play with this cool doctor down the
street we're going to do these things
and never i will go to the ends of the
earth because i love you so much
and you can't go play with those boys
anymore period
and you and your husband are going to
demonstrate that by having a hard
conversation with them too
all of this stuff adds an ethos and at
home to my mom and dad got my back
even when it's hard and messy and ugly
and screwy and scary they got my back
ah and i got a five-year-old too
ugh having kids man thank you so much
for that call brooke
hey real quick i know we're up against
the end of the show
i want to um this is an awesome email i
want to get to real quick it says this
my college age daughter is a bridesmaid
in her cousin's wedding
and the expenses are outrageous the
bachelorette party is out of town so she
must pay for flights hotel food and
pre-selected gifts
for the bride she was also given a color
palette for her wardrobe selections for
the weekend
meaning she has to buy some new clothes
now she is told that there if there are
any overages incurred by the party the
bridesmaids must be prepared to cover
them
even if they are not their charges how
can she talk to her cousin and tell her
she can't afford this without causing
problems
you can't a problem has been dropped in
your lap
and what you have to do is stand up and
drop it on the floor
like who like it's hot correct right
so you call your cousin and say i've
done the math
being a part of your wedding is gonna
cost me five thousand dollars or
seven thousand dollars and i can't do it
i'm so grateful for the invite
i really appreciate it but i'm sitting
this one out
i look forward to watching the stream
online or
whatever but i'm out i'm out
if you want to do this if you want to
have some kind of fancy wedding i'm all
for it
knock your lights out
but man you got to help out your
bridesmaids
to asking people to spend five seven ten
thousand dollars to travel across the
country to make your vision
of your fantasy day come true it's just
not cool man
it's not cool so is there a way to do
this without causing problems
nope the problem's already been caused
all you can do is take care of you
and set your own boundaries thank you
for that email i didn't have a name on
this one we're just gonna call this
pretty much everyone on earth tada
we're gonna call her susan i'm gonna
call her susan no let's call her
james we'll call it james you're not a
bridesmaid are you i don't know why i
went there that wasn't cool
all right as we wrap up today's show
what this is actually from kelly kelly
this from you
is this your email
you were
no i was not that way i could see that
denim all denim
i wore camo
hey she didn't wear camo there's gonna
be a few of you like i like kelly she
wore a camo at her wedding it's awesome
all right as we wrap up today's show oh
man
off the board in the usa album an
incredible song by the master
poet himself bruce springsteen dance in
the dark and it goes like this
i get up in the evening and i got
nothing to say i come home in the
morning
i go to bed feeling the same way i ain't
nothing but tired
man i'm just tired and bored with myself
hey there baby i can just use a little
help
you can't start a fire you can't start a
fire without
a spark this gun's for hire even
if we're just dancing in the dark what a
tune man
everybody go listen to dancing in the
dark and tell me if you're not dancing
in the dark this has been the dr john
dolone's show
[Music]
you